[موسيقى]
تستمر الحرب على ملف الطاقه بين روسيا
والاتحاد الاوروبي سيالا وتبدو في ثناياها
مختلف الاستراتيجيات على اثر قرار الاتحاد
الاوروبي ودول مجموعه السبع واستراليا فرض
السقف 60 دولارا بسعر برميل النفط الروسي
بدايه الشهر الجاري لوحه موسكو بامكانيه
تخفيض انتاجها من النفط بما يتراوحو بين
75% في اوائل العام القادم
نائب رئيس الوزراء الروسيه
الطاقه للاسواق الاخرى وان الاولويه ستكون
لدول اسيا والمحيط الهادي وافريقيا
وامريكا اللاتينيه
وبجاني مركز توزيع الغاز المزمع انشاؤه في
تركيا نوه نوفاك الى امكانيه مشاركه دول
اخرى مصدره للغاز في المركز بجانب روسيا
مشيرا الى ان الغاز الروسي رخيص الثمن
ومطلوب في الاسواق حديث نوفاك عن المركز
ياتي بعد ايامنا اتصال هاتفي للرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان مع نظيره الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين بحث الرئيس خلاله المصالح
المشتركه في مجال الطاقه ومقترحه انشائي
مركز اقليميا لتصدير الغاز في اسطنبول
وكان الرئيس التركي قد استبق تلك
المحادثات الهاتفيه بلقاء الرئيس التنفيذي
لشركه غاز بروم الروسيه اليكسيميلر
والتاكيد على ان تركيا وموسكو سيعملان
فورا على تنفيذي مقترح بوتن الخاص بالنقل
الغاز الروسي عبر تركيا الى القاره
الاوروبيه
الثابت الان بعد توقف امدادات الغاز
الروسي لاوروبا عبر انابيب نور ستريم واحد
ونور ستريم فان كميات اقل تصل عبر
الانابيب العاب راي الى القاره الاوروبيه
من اوكرانيا و بلغاريا وتقدر باقل من 10%
مما تستهلكه دول القاره
الاتحاد الاوروبي ينظر الطبعا بعين الريبه
لهذا التجارب الروس التركي ووصفه مفوض
السياسي الخارجي للاتحاد الاوروبي جزء
بوريل عدم استعداد تركيا للانضمام الى
العقوبات الغربيه على روسيا بانه مدعاه
للقلق
وكان وزراء الطاقه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
هذه اتفقوا يوم الاثنين الماضي بشان تحديد
السقف لاسعار الغاز الطبيعي عند 180 يورو
للميجاوات في الساعه وبموت بقرار الاتحاد
فان السقف المحدد سيدخل حيز التنفيذ في
منتصف فبراير القاد
والان وبعد ان اعتبرت روسيا لاتفاق مرفودا
فانها قد تبدا في تنفيذ ما حذرت منه الغرب
حاله الاقتراب من اسعار غاز الطبيعي وهو
ما يوحي باستمرار الحرب على ملف الطاقه
حتى بعد انقضاء فصل الشتاء الحالي